hey this is presh talwalkar
jess wants 200 ribbons of length 110
centimeters for a party
however the ribbons were sold at 25
meters per tape
how many tapes will just need
this problem is sparking controversy
because it was given to primary school
students in singapore
however many adults could not solve this
problem and felt it was too tricky to be
given to 12 year old students
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
while this problem is not too difficult
it is fairly tricky and i myself came up
with the wrong answer by using the wrong
approach
the first pitfall is that the problem
involves multiple units of measurement
so we need to make sure to use only one
unit of measurement
i will convert everything to meters
the first step i'll say that the 110
centimeters of each ribbon equals 1.1
meters for each ribbon
next
i multiplied the 1.1 meters by the 200
ribbons that were needed to get the
total length of 220 meters
i then took that total length and
divided by the 25 meters per tape to get
that there would be 8.8 tapes needed to
produce that length
i then said since 8 tapes are too few we
would need 9 tapes in total
but this is the wrong answer
in fact 10 tapes are needed
why use that
the reason is we shouldn't be
considering just the total length of
ribbon but we need to consider
how much ribbon is used per tape
each tape has 25 meters
so we need to take the 25 meters per
tape and divide it by the 1.1 meters per
ribbon
we end up that each tape can produce 22
whole ribbons
plus an excess amount but this is not a
whole ribbon amount it's less than one
so each tape can make 22 whole ribbons
and then we're going to have some excess
material which is going to be wasted
now technically you could try and
combine this excess material between the
tapes but nowhere in the problem does it
say that you can do that so you would
likely have to assume that the excess
material goes wasted so you would have
to say that each tape can produce 22
whole ribbons
from there
we know that we need 200 total ribbons
so we divide that by the 22 ribbons per
tape to get that we'll need 9 plus 1
over 11 tapes
in other words we'll need more than 9
tapes since 9 tapes are too few we will
need 10 tapes to produce all the 200
ribbons
so this is a fairly tricky question
and getting to the correct answer of 10
tapes requires
some thoughtful process of considering
the dimensions
and the excess material of each tape
did you figure out this problem
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions which you can follow on
facebook google plus and patreon you can
catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description